I want to talk a little bit about
hypocrisy and it's not the usual
hypocrisy from the American right it's
actually hypocrisy from the American
democratic party let me set it up for
you Donald Trump has only been in office
at this point about 26 days okay
and during those 26 days there have been
a ton of different leaks okay ranging
from Donald Trump doesn't think the
towels on Air Force One are soft enough
to Donald Trump didn't know at 3 a.m.
whether a weak dollar or a strong dollar
was better for America so he called a
former national security adviser Michael
Flynn a guy who has no economic
knowledge whatsoever to ask him what he
thinks two leaks like finding out that
Donald Trump is demanding memos on a
single page in bullet point format
mostly with pictures and maps because he
doesn't like reading this stuff and now
the real reason that Michael Flynn was
forced to resign was because again
someone in intelligence leaked the
contents of his call to Russian
officials potentially a crime was
committed there were not exactly sure
but what's clear is there were just
out-and-out lies Michael Flynn denying
that the issue of Russian sanctions came
up during those conversations it turns
out that they did and as a result of the
week Michael Flynn is gone so let me
first remind you of the obvious and
hilarious double standard with regard to
leaks and intelligence from Donald Trump
and Republicans during the 2016 election
Republicans didn't seem to mind that DNC
emails were being hacked and leaked that
information related to Hillary Clinton's
email server was being hacked and leaked
and they would say constantly hey hey
hey don't worry about how it was leaked
or the legality of the leaks or whether
hacking took place just focus on the
content and what we're learning that's
all that matters that was the line from
Republicans during the 2016 election and
in a general sense I sort of agree with
the sentiment we should be focusing on
what the content reveals to us so now we
have total and utter hypocrisy from the
Trump administer
Republicans all of a sudden after we're
learning so much about the Trump
relationship with Russia as a result of
weeks Republicans and ours saying hey
ignore the content of the leaks we need
to be focusing on the fact that someone
in intelligence leaked this stuff we
need to be looking into whether hacking
took place with anything that benefits
the Republican Party they look the other
way when it comes to the illegal or
morally dubious procuring or disclosing
of information but when it's something
that doesn't benefit them they want to
ignore the content and focus on the
legality or the moral of sort of
circumstances of the information fine we
know about that double standard
unfortunately there are many
establishment Democrats that are guilty
of the exact same thing and it's really
not being discussed too much right now
Democrats are singing the praises for
the reality that this very damning
information about the Donald Trump staff
and connections with Russia etc is being
leaked but it was only one
administration ago under President
Barack Obama a Democrat that many
Democrats were condemning the actions of
many people like Edward Snowden or
Chelsea Manning etc those leakers at the
time particularly Edward Snowden were
undermining a democratic White House and
many Democrats not all but many
Democrats were emphasizing the
illegality of the leaks above and beyond
what did we find out and many Democrats
have the position that yes this is
important for us to know but we have the
rule of law we cannot commend crime we
cannot commend the disclosure of
classified or secret information that's
the exact position of Republicans right
now that Democrats are criticizing and
we can't allow Pat partisanship to fog
our principles beneficial leaks are
beneficial leaks you can say what and
I've said this actually quite often Pat
as you've heard me say I don't commend
or suggest
the breaking of the law period however
when we have information and I've
applied this across the board we should
look at the subject matter the content
and the believability of that
information that should be the focus
leaks aren't automatically less
righteous if they occur when a
Democratic president is in the White
House right I tend to agree with you and
you have to be consistent because
otherwise it just comes off as if you're
playing for Team Democrat or team
Republican I mean with regards to leaks
I think the information that comes out
of them is more important and I think
honestly leaking and information and
being a whistleblower can be justified
if you're doing so in the American
interest now there may be some penalties
those people have to pay but if it's
worth it to them I mean I think that can
be a good thing and I've made the
distinction before and I'm sure some
people will email me and they'll say
David hold on a second though you've
distinguished between types of leaks in
the past based on how the information
was obtained let me repeat what I've
said in the past when we talk about a
leak verse a leaker versus a
whistleblower Chelsea Manning exposed
actions that were against the law or the
Army Field Manual the way that the Army
on paper says it conducts itself whereas
Edward Snowden leaked information that
while we may find it deplorable or
spying techniques that are ineffective
it was legal by statute at the time so
that's a distinction I've made that
still doesn't change whether we should
focus on the content or not it's a
separate conversation from if and
whether there should be legal
repercussions for the leaker /
whistleblower send me your thoughts
about this a lot of people emailing me
and asking me to to address what they're
seeing as this hypocrisy double standard
from some Democrats I'm glad to do it
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show is
on Twitter a David Pakman show let me
know what you think today's show is
brought to you by go daddy where you can
buy your own domain name build a website
or use any of Go Daddy's business tools
you can save
thirty percent at try godaddy.com slash
David GoDaddy has actually been the
official host of the David Pakman show
website for many many many years the
24/7 customer support has been a very
good thing for us I've called them at
really odd times when we've had website
issues and they are always available
they are the largest domain registrar
and whether you have a new idea you're
an established business you're creating
a personal website or moving your large
enterprise site over to GoDaddy they can
do it all thirteen million customers try
it and get 30% off at try go daddy.com
slash David